distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen dear friends
when we started preparations for this
first european humanitarian forum
no one could have imagined that it would
coincide with the worst humanitarian
crisis in decades on european soil
almost three and a half million people
have already left ukraine
half of them children
we are seeing heartbreaking scenes at
ukrainian train stations women and
children
wave at their husbands fathers and
brothers
through a train window
knowing it could be their last goodbye
in response to this emergency thousands
of european families have opened their
homes
countless associations and ngos are
providing clothes shelter medicines
or sending buses to drive ukrainians to
safety
all european member states are doing
their part
to help them
we have made sure that european funds
can be used with utmost flexibility in
support of refugees
and we are proposing to allocate an
additional 3 billion euros
to support our member states that are
welcoming our friends in need
yet the consequences of the kremlin's
aggression of ukraine span well beyond
europe
ukraine is the granary of the world
ukraine alone provides more than half of
the world food programs we supply
countries like somalia rely entirely on
ukraine and russia for their wheat
imports
this kremlin-made war is threatening
food security across the world
and this is adding on
an already dire situation
humanitarian needs are at an all-time
high
because our world is still shattered by
too many conflicts from syria to yemen
from the sahel to ethiopia
from afghanistan to myanmar
never in the history of the world have
there been so many refugees
millions of them are hosted in
low-income countries
and all of this
while climate change threatens millions
of lives all across the world
we risk entering a new age of famine
in too many parts of the world
the european union has set aside over
2.5 billion euros until 2024
to help the regions most affected by
food insecurity
we will be readying a range of special
measures to step up european food
production
also in support of countries most in
need
europe is the world's largest
humanitarian donor
we call on others to step up their
contributions to
because the world needs humanitarian
action more than ever before
this is a moment for all
those who share a humanitarian spirit to
join forces
europe will stay committed and do its
part